[Musik]
parteien sind in niedersachsen knapp
14.000 einwohner eigentlich viel zu
klein für die große grüne wahlkampftour
trotzdem kommen die kamerateams die
partei wirbt offensiv mit dem termin
denn annalena baerbock ist in pattensen
aufgewachsen heimspiel flügel grüne
kanzlerkandidatin hier bin ich geboren
gelebt meine familie und vor allem hier
habe ich gelernt was wichtig ist im
leben
gelungene auftritte
positive bilder das braucht berbalk vor
allem weil der einstieg in den wahlkampf
komplett misslungen ist
annalena baerbock
kanzlerkandidaten der heute noch
kleinsten partei bundestag hat deutlich
an wind unter den flügeln verloren
unsauberkeiten im lebenslauf nicht
gemeldete nebeneinkünfte vieles läuft
nicht rund im berg wahlkampfes gab
versorgen dass es gab fehler die
zugegeben werden mussten und es geht
offenbar weiter es gibt stellen in
diesem buch das sind texte teilweise
oder tatsächlich komplett aus anderen
quellen übernommen wurden in dem glauben
in mikro stand ausgeschaltet rutscht ihr
gut hörbar ein vernichtender kommentar
heraus
jetzt bläst der wind ganz schön von
vorne das ist in so einem wahlkampf so
wahlkampf kommt ja auch von kämpfen das
tun wir das tun tue ich aber ich habe
auch eigene fehler gemacht darüber
ärgere ich mich tierisch und werde
versuchen jetzt umso stärker das
vertrauen gezogen
[Musik]
anna lena charlotte alma berbalk
1980 geborenen hannover mit zwei
schwestern aufgewachsen in pattensen
schon als kleines kind nehmen die eltern
sie mit auf friedensdemonstrationen
hobbys in der schulzeit fußball und
trampolinspringen
dreimal dritter bei den deutschen
meisterschaften ihre frühere trainerin
meint der leistungssport habe berbalk
geprägt
sie kamen gerne zum trampolin turner ich
habe sehr gerne mit ihr trainiert sie
war unkompliziert
sie war verlässlich
zielstrebig bei der sache
bernburg studiert politikwissenschaft
und völkerrecht in hamburg und london
2005 tritt sie bei den grünen ein
arbeitet im büro einer grünen
europaabgeordneten und zieht nach
potsdam 2009 wird sie zur ko
vorsitzenden der grünen in brandenburg
gewählt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
erklärtes ziel damals
parteistrukturen professionalisieren und
das image ablegen von der im osten
schwachen nischenpartei
umwelt und naturschutz haben jetzt die
mitte der gesellschaft erreicht und
dafür stehen wir grünen seit jahren das
macht uns glaubwürdig dass wir seit 20
jahren für den atomausstieg kämpfen und
heute immer noch und ich glaube da
merken auch leute das ist nicht nur
geschwätz was ich morgen wieder
vergessen habe sondern das bleibt
2009 kandidiert werburg noch erfolglos
für den bundestag
2013 tritt sie auf landeslistenplatz 1
an und
schafft den einzug ins parlament
[Musik]
dass hier ein anderes tempo ist das
merkt man schon dass auch die eindrücke
und die nachfragen viel intensiver sind
als auf landesebene
das wird schon deutlich
morgen
und feiern und hässliche
fraktionssitzungen laufen ich emotional
annalena baerbock wird klimapolitische
sprecherin der bundestagsfraktion und
sprecherin der landesgruppe ost
der box zweite tochter kommt zur welt
und wenig später mit ins parlament
parteivorsitzende sind zu der zeit
simone peter und cem özdemir interner
spitzname duo infernale weil sie ständig
gegeneinander arbeiten sich auf nichts
einigen können
nach einer enttäuschenden bundestagswahl
2017 wollen die grünen neue gesichter
und einen neuen stil
robert habeck wird ohne gegenkandidaten
zum neuen parteivorsitzenden gewählt
annalena baerbock setzt sich in einer
kampfabstimmung gegen eine kandidatin
vom linken flügel durch
endlich mitregieren das ist seitdem die
mission und dafür werden die zügel kurz
gehalten bei den grünen war es aus
meiner sicht in den letzten jahren nicht
mehr so dass das wirklich ernsthaft
öffentlich über positionen gerungen
wurde sondern da wurde alles hinter
verschlossener tür geregelt es wurde
dann für den parteitag irgendeinen
kompromiss gefunden mit dem alle
irgendwie leben konnten der aber
vielleicht auch nicht ja auch nicht der
beste kompromiss war sondern so ein
formelkompromiss das habe ich schon als
als einen mangel an lebendigkeit
wahrgenommen
die lebendigkeit leidet die umfragewerte
steigen sogar das kanzleramt scheint
erreichbar die grüne k frage kommt auf
robert habeck wäre gern der kandidat
geworden aber berbalk setzt sich durch
wir beide haben uns darauf vorbereitet
wir beide wollten ist aber am ende kann
es nur eine machen liebe anna lena bitte
die bühne gehört hier
die kandidatinnen kühe glück danach
glück nicht mehr viel berbalk muss
einkünfte nachmelden sie muss
beschönigende angaben in ihrem
lebenslauf korrigieren und sie muss
eingestehen
dass sie bei ihrem buch extra für den
wahlkampf geschrieben
abgekupfert hat
annalena baerbock will offensichtlich
oder wollte immer ein bisschen schöner
und größer erscheinen als sie wirklich
ist also wenn man sein lebenslauf
frisiert und wenn man ein buch schreibt
mitten im wahlkampf um noch gedankliche
tiefe zu signalisieren und das ist dann
eben mit 50 stellen durchzogen ist das
ein problem weil man denkt na ja so
richtig integer ist diese frau
vielleicht nicht auch ein problem die
weniger box wahlkampf zündet desto
größer wird die frage wäre es mit habig
besser gelaufen der co-vorsitzende
kokettiert mit seinem schmerz nach der
verpassten kandidatur und führt den
wahlkampf den berg führen sollte
das war ja klar dass es gegenwind gibt
und zürich wird aber die fehler haben
natürlich hier gemacht das ist da gibt
es keinen grund um zu heilen
also fehler abstellen und dann starken
wahlkampf von der kanzlerschaft reden
die grünen mittlerweile auffallend
selten dafür umso mehr von ihrem
kernthema dem klimaschutz hallo zusammen
wir
weiter sagen wir warten mal ein paar
jahre ab wie das die bundesregierung in
den letzten jahren getan hat dann werden
wir die klimakrise nicht in den griff
bekommen und wir gefährden die freiheit
unserer kinder
bernburgs wahlkampfreden enden immer mit
einem appell bei dieser wahl ging es um
den mut zur veränderung um
weichenstellungen für jahrzehnte
und noch sei alles offen
[Musik]